um
at the global scale and all smaller
scales that's part of what multi-level
selection is about can you explain the
difference between multi-level selection
and
group selection is it just a rebranding
uh so let's talk about the difference
between multi-level selection and
and uh group selection and in the
process let's
define for viewers who are not
um already knowledgeable about this kind
of stuff what some of the issues are
at stake and so going all the way back
to darwin darwin thought
that his theory could explain all
aspects of design
that had been attributed to a creator
everything that works has a functional
basis
he thought that had been attributed to
creator
and he thought he could explain with his
theory of natural selection
but upon further thought he came against
a dilemma
which is if you think of anything that
we associate with morality
if i asked you to define the morally
perfect individual
you would use adjectives such as
altruistic loving giving honest
brave all of these are
things that benefit others and one
society
as a whole and often involve some cost
to the moral individual
and so when darwin contemplated the
moral individual
compared to his or her opposite the
immoral individual
well it's the immoral individual that
has the advantage
in the struggle for existence there's
something associated with all forms of
goodness
that's vulnerable to all forms of
uh evil and so darwin could not explain
everything associated with virtue as a
product of natural
selection unless he added something and
that something was to think about
natural selection
at a slightly larger scale so while
altruism is vulnerable to selfishness
within any given social group
it's also the case that a group of
altruists a group of virtuous
people will robustly outcompete a group
of
people who cannot cohere and so now we
do have a process of natural selection
that can favor virtue but it's a process
that takes place
at the level of groups not at the level
of competition among individuals within
groups
and so there's group selection is two
level selection
it looks at what's what happens within
groups competition among individuals
within groups
and then what happens with competitions
among groups
in some kind of multi-group population
a group inhabited by many tribes as
darwin
talked about it so you could call that
two-level selection
now multi-level selection simply expands
that it goes up and down
going down we can talk about genes
within individual
so a gene can succeed at the expense of
other genes within the same
organism we call that cancer
and there's many examples of that kind
of selfish gene
or genes can can evolve by cooperating
with other genes in the organism in
which case
natural selection is taking place at the
level of organisms out competing other
organisms so it's the same dynamic that
i just described
except it's genes and organisms then we
get to organisms
in groups and do you know those groups
of groups of groups
so we could talk about ecosystems for
example our microbiomes it turns out
that you are not just
a homogenous collection of genes you are
a planet inhabited by
many thousands of of microbial species
numbering in the trillions
of individuals and when you're selected
when you
when you survive and reproduce better
than others in part it's due not to your
genes but to your
microbiome and the good microbiomes are
being selected
along with the good genes and they're
interacting
with uh each other in other words
what we think of as individual selection
is actually group selection when you
think about the collection
it turns out the microbiomes is a game
changer because
before we were kind of on to that
concept of microbiomes
it seemed that we were
a relatively uniform collection of
of genes we start out as a single egg
and then those cells divide and divide
and divide but they all have the same
genes
well not really because actually
mutations are occurring with every
cell division and by the time you get to
my age do you know
you know i'm a very diverse entity
at this point even my genes the extra
mutations
have resulted in all sorts of of uh
they're called neoplasms but they're
basically cell lines that have
proliferated more than the normal
uh cell lines and that's what cancers
are based basically so
but anyhow so
for the most part except for that then
um
all of our all of our genes are
are identical in all of our cells so
that makes us a pretty potent
unit of selection that made individual
level selection
to be a very very strong uh
force okay well it still is i mean
nothing has changed except the
the realization that uh we're not such
homogeneous entities after all we're
some kind of ecosystem
and it's actually hard to know who's
calling the shots so
you know this is um one of the very
interesting developments that have taken
place over the last
30 years which have revolutionized
the study of evolution that's just one
that we'll be covering during this
conversation